hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to show you how to compute yourself
the synthetic showed interest and most
importantly i would like to show you
what i have for amc compared to the
other stocks and
see what this means in terms of market
dynamics for amc so let's get into it
[Music]
alright so very quickly i'm showing you
the chart here again but i've already
done an analysis using this data during
the weekend
so not much to say let me just remind
you the most important information in
this technical analysis is that we have
the breakout here around 34.5
i moved a little bit this trend line to
be really you know closer to the price
action on the short term here i matched
the the high and hit the low so this is
the proper trend line i want to have and
we are retesting this uh upper band here
the blue one perfectly we are moving
higher this looks very good to me but
once again amc price action is full of
tricks especially like uh for the past
month to month but this is kind of i
would say happening often during those
correction phases they are very hard to
trade a nice bullish move is much easier
you know it's respecting much better
every ratio and all the technical
analysis uh tools that we can use so
here just to conclude we need to see the
price turning above 34.5 closing ideally
on the hourly timeframe above this level
and so means one out one full hour of
turning above 24.7
let's be very precise 34.7 this would
mean further upside movement for me
probably going to 40 or 46. but here
guys what i want to show you because i
fixed my spreadsheet so you didn't see
this for a while okay very quickly it's
not this one sorry
okay it's this one i'm using here
bloomberg data so that's why i couldn't
use it for a while because you know i
had the bloomberg license from my
company now i took my own bloomberg
license so i'm not allowed to show you
uh the details of this analysis but i
can show you the conclusion
so basically what i'm doing is that i
get all the open interest option open
interest for every strike every maturity
all right guys you can see this is what
i put in here okay so i i take the
strikes from 11
to 200 so basically i have all the
strikes every maturity my maturities are
here guys and i just computed uh compute
the delta myself for every volatility uh
so that's why i need bloomberg to get
the volatility as you can see here this
is a bloomberg formula so this is the
reason why without bloomberg it's
impossible to get or you need to have uh
other information that gives you the
volatility per strike prematurity then
it's just basic black shots formula
that you apply and you get all the open
positions for the call options i'm only
here considering the corruptions which
is a fair assumption i don't take into
account to put up an interest because
you never know who is long put okay you
know that retail is on call so you know
that market makers are short calls or
hedge funds
so you can guess the dynamics on this
market because you know that those guys
they are usually hedging the position
every day but you don't know who is
buying the put options they can be
retail that protects the long share
position and it can be also hedge funds
or market makers betting on an amc crash
so that's why i don't take here into
account to put up an interest which is
anyway much lower and
when i compute this for amc guys i have
right now so you can see per strike
here in
yellow it's the number of shares so you
can see that the highest number of
shares is here yes for the 145 strike we
have uh
145 14 million equivalent share ceiling
here all right so this is very unusual
here is the option open interest
breakdown per strike and you can see
that we have a lot here definitely but
we have a big one here those are a bit
small to me and if you take the sum of
it you have 6.3 at the current spot and
it can reach 15
if all the options are finishing in the
money so this would be for example uh a
price of amc
equal to another amc goes to 200 you can
see that we are converging towards this
and if mc goes to 500 okay we are very
very close so it's almost a perfect
convergence all right so this is the
first important uh thing i want you to
show yourself we have six point three
percent of synthetic short interest we
have 16.7 percent of uh synthetic
regular short interest so
the sum of it is 23
which is a lot let me show you for
example another stock that is training
you know that has normal open interest i
just take april for example ma'am
okay you're gonna see
so now everything is messed up now apple
is not too bad you can see all the
information is here
so we have only 0.6 of synthetic short
interest okay and regular shot 0.6 so
you can see the difference between apple
and amc so this is a normal stock all
right so basically you can see that the
synthetic short is the maximum is 1.4
percent now if i go for example to jim
very interesting let's have a look at
jimmy
bam so here my strikes are not good so i
need to update it bam so i'm updating
you're gonna see the magic happening
okay i'm just rebuilding everything here
all right here we go guys so you can see
that the option open interest breakdown
per strike there are a lot everywhere
but you have a bit less on the very high
strikes around you know 300 percent than
you have on amc but uh the maximum
synthetic shot is still 13.7 percent so
it's still very very unusual but as gme
is quite low we only have
uh 3.6
of synthetic short at this spot but once
again if gme goes i don't know to uh
four times this
okay you can see we go to ten percent so
this is you know what is forcing the
market makers and hedge funds to buy
back the positions if the price is going
higher so this is the first information
i wanted to show you maybe we can do one
more i don't know just oh we can do
tesla
okay
just like yes
get synthetic short okay i'm recomputing
everything
give it some time
okay okay okay for now this is not
correct it's still using past data don't
worry it's going to reset soon
okay here we go so you see tesla is
actually not that much shorted on the
regular market only three percent but
look at the very high synthetic short
for example on tesla so this is
interesting it means that a lot of
people don't believe tesla can go two
thousand or two thousand i mean a lot of
people believe this and market makers
are ready to sell it let's have a look
at the volatility for example on tesla
it's interesting you know because market
makers they're going to sell it if the
vault is very high but i don't think the
vault is very high so let's see first
where these big positions are coming
from
so which is the biggest one for example
the 1000
1000 is quite big so i go to the 1000
strike
okay i have 6 million equivalent share
let's see where it's coming from
okay so mostly from here
22 000
okay so mostly from gen 22 gen 23 and
the volatility guys is not that high is
only 50
so to me this is a very actually nice
trade to do you know to go and buy this
volatility because it's not high for amc
guys it's around 200 percent on the stem
strikes 150 strike let's have a look for
amc
what is the volatility
okay
so 145 strike
sorry 150
you see volatility is around 120 130
depending on the maturity you look at so
three four times more than tesla so for
this reason you actually don't want to
be buying this 145 strike but
you know it's kind of
maybe a worthy sacrifice because it's
very expensive it's free money for
market makers as long as amc is trading
below 145 but this is as well what is
creating this gamma squeeze let me
explain again when amc goes higher those
market makers position
that are shorting those 145 strike calls
their shot position increases in the
same way that the long position of the
call options holders is increasing on
the upside so those guys that are
selling it they become short so they
have to buy back some shares to buy just
some shares in order to be hedged
because market makers don't keep a short
position overnight so that's why they
need to buy whenever the spot is going
higher but i'm very sure you guys heard
it already everywhere because it's
something that many people talk about
but i just wanted to explain it once
again quickly so it's good that some
people buy it
because it's gonna help to create the
squeeze
but this is a waste of money let's be
honest all right when you buy it such
expensive volatility it's not good so
this is the reason why what i am showing
you guys here and i am
i'm gonna discuss this with you guys
that are on my discord uh tonight i will
try i just want to add some cool
features in this option strategy builder
spreadsheet
so for example for amc you can see that
the kind of strategy that i'm proposing
you guys so here you have the maturity
so let's go for example for the
september maturity it's good because
let's imagine that this week we go much
higher and that the squeeze begins you
don't know
so maybe we're gonna
here
i don't need this one
okay so this is the kind of strategy
that i showed you guys already uh i'm
gonna keep showing you this kind of
strategy what i'm doing here so let's
start from scratch
okay
first uh 24 is support i'm talking about
this for a long time so i'm not scared
to sell this put all right this is free
money i can get so now that amc spot is
higher it's not worth a lot but it's
still interesting to sell it then you
can buy one for this try call white 40
because 40 is a support level all right
so by doing this the call option cost
370 us dollar but
you reduce it by 140 and we're gonna
keep reducing it because as you saw the
very high strikes uh have a very high
volatility look here 137 132 and this
one is 245
so guys don't buy this high volt strikes
okay you sell it but you're not gonna
sell it by itself naked you're gonna buy
the 40 strike before so you have a long
position so here
we sell it bam
and by doing that we reduce again the
premium we pay by doing that you're
gonna pay 150 us dollar in premium and
you can make up to eight thousand even
nine thousand us dollars if amc goes uh
230 what you can do as well if you don't
want to spend any money you go to 50
strikes and now it's for free
so because the 50 strike cold call is
less expensive than the 4d strike call
the only difference is that you're going
to start making money only here i want
to add some features i think we can add
a lot of things i can add the gamma the
delta the video and i want to walk you
through this once again tonight or
tomorrow guys on my discord so go there
and i will try to show you a lot of
different option strategies on many
stocks i will also try to show you you
know the option open interest if you're
interested you know anything that can be
helpful for you guys and that i think is
important to understand to uh better
analyze a market dynamics and price
action so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys